What's the Difference Between Partly Cloudy
and Mostly Sunny?
If you ever thought it was difficult to tell
the difference between “partly cloudy”
and “mostly sunny,” you’re not alone.
Established by the National Weather Service
(NWS) according to a loose set of rules, the
criteria used to describe different elements
of your forecast can be pretty vague.
Sky conditions are classified according to
how much “opaque cloud coverage” (OCC)
is expected that day.
While the NWS has apparently not defined “opaque
clouds,” they are presumed to be those that
can’t be seen through, or more technically,
those that are “opaque to terrestrial radiation.”
To qualify as “Sunny,” there can be no
more than 25% OCC.
“Clear,” on the other hand is sometimes
used as synonym for “Sunny,” but is only
applied when there is no more than 5% OCC.
“Mostly Clear,” which is also a synonym
for “Sunny,” is used when there is between
6% and 25% OCC.
“Mostly Sunny” and “Partly Cloudy”
are apparently interchangeable, and apply
when the OCC is between 26% and 50%.”Partly
Sunny” and “Mostly Cloudy” can also
be synonyms, when the OCC is between 51% and
69%, although “Mostly Cloudy” can be applied
for OCC up to 87%.
At an OCC of 88% and above, the sky is considered
“Cloudy” or “Overcast.”
Note that when there is a “high probability”
of precipitation (60% or more), many weather
folks skip the sky condition forecast, since
it may be inferred to be “Cloudy.”
When forecasting the chance of precipitation,
the NWS considers the likelihood that there
will be at least 0.01 inches of precipitation
at one place in the forecast area within (usually)
a 12-hour period (called the probability of
precipitation or POP).
Words used in the forecast, such as “chance
of rain” and “likely,” as well as “isolated”
and “scattered,” are considered either
“expressions of uncertainty” or “qualifiers”
(the last two denote that the entire area
will not be affected), and they are tied to
ranges of POPs.
So, when the probability of precipitation
(POP) is between 60% and 70%, the “uncertainty”
is low and so the forecast may often include
the word “likely,” while when the POP
is only 20%, the “uncertainty” is higher,
so the phrase “slight chance,” may be
used.
“Isolated” is used when the POP is between
10% and 29%, while “scattered” is used
when the POP is between 30% and 59%.
“Occasional,” “intermittent,” and
“periods of,” denote a POP of greater
than 79%, but also that the precipitation
will be “on and off.”
When the forecast temperature is given in
a range, it has a particular meaning, as well.
For example, “near 40” means the temperature
is expected to be anywhere from 38F to 42F,
“lower 40s” denotes anywhere from 40F
to 44F, “mid 40s” from 43F to 47F and
“upper 40s” from 46F to 49F.
Wind terms are tied to specific ranges too,
all related to “sustained wind speed”
(SWS), and they can overlap.
“Sustained wind” is defined as the average
of observed wind speeds over a two-minute
period.
“High,” “strong” and “damaging”
winds are those expected to have SWS of at
least 40 miles per hour (mph).
“Very windy” denotes when SWS is between
30 and 40 mph, and “windy” between anywhere
from 20 to 35 mph.
When the SWS is between 15 and 25 mph, “breezy”
is used when the weather is mild, and “brisk”
or “blustery” are used when it is cold.
“Calm” and “light” are used to denote
SWS of 5 mph or less.
Wind chill incorporates considerations of
how much heat a human body will lose to the
environment on a cold or windy day.
Calculations are estimated at weather conditions
at 5 feet above ground level (said to be the
typical height of a human face), and begin
when SWS reach 3 mph.
The NWS provides a chart that shows wind chill
for any temperature between 40F and -45F with
winds between 5 mph and 60 mph, and it reveals
that even a slight wind, with cold temperatures,
can have a big effect on wind chill.
For example, at 0F with only calm winds of
5 mph, the wind chill is -11F.
Likewise, even when temperatures are relatively
mild, say at 35F, if the winds are high, say
60 mph, it can make it feel about half the
temperature it really is (17F).
On the other hand, the heat index reflects
the fact that when the humidity reaches a
certain point, the perspiration on your skin
can’t evaporate, you can’t cool down so
easily, and so the apparent temperature feels
hotter than it actually is.
On that note, the NWS provides a heat index
chart as well, which shows temperatures between
80F and 110F and relative humidity (RH) between
40% and 100%.
Just as with wind chill, slight changes in
a single variable can have a dramatic effect,
and when both are high, the heat index becomes
dangerous to human health.
For example, at 90F and 40% RH, the heat index
is only 91F, but if it’s soupy outside,
say 95% RH, then the heat index shoots up
to 127F.